my name is Kate gray with' I'm a
renegade economist because I am
passionate about rewriting economics so
that it's fit for the 21st century
[Music]
here's the fascinating thing I think
we're living through a psychological
drama in terms of what business can be
and do in the world the 20th century was
dominated by one narrow business mindset
that asked one overriding question how
much financial value can we extract from
this but 21st century business leaders
designers city designers they're asking
a completely different question how many
benefits can we generate in the way we
designed this what else can it do for
the community for culture for the living
world what else can it give back to the
systems of which we're part you see 20th
century industry was degenerative by the
design we would take Earth's materials
make them into things we want use it for
a while and throw it away this is a
linear degenerative economy it cuts
against the cycles of the living world
we need to bend that around so that
resources are never used up they used
again and again so that we create an
economy that runs on sunlight that
wastes from one process is food for
another we work with and within the
cycles of the living world
the thing is business alone can't make
this happen creating a circular
regenerative economy imagine if every
company said send us that shirt on your
back that smartphone that plastic bottle
return it to us and we'll turn it back
into something new we'd have a loop here
we'd have another loop over here we'd
have a series of segmented loops nature
would laugh at us Nature doesn't turn a
peacock back into a peacock and a
daffodil back into a daffodil nature
creates an ecosystem of resources she
turns things back into building books of
oxygen nitrogen hydrogen and build them
up again regenerating life again and
again from building blocks through an
ecosystem no one company can create an
ecosystem we need cities and we need
States we need the world to work
together to create ecosystems of
Plastics reuse of textiles reuse of
metals reuse so that we work with and
within the cycles of the living world we
mimic nature who's been thriving for 3.8
billion years if we want to stick around
we'd be wise to learn from her well I
never travel without a bit of hose pipe
this came from my garden shed
[Music]